J. Horton, Filmmaker/Youtuber/Podcaster:
But I really wish somebody had
made it known to me that like
you don’t necessarily have to be
Quentin Tarantino to make a living
making movies. Film Courage:
What’s the one thing you wish someone had a
heart-to-heart talk with you and said this is
what’s going to happen and this where it’s going
to be hard and you learned it on your own and
I wish that someone had set me down and been
more realistic in your expectations of what
your career is going to be or what it takes
to make a living as a filmmaker? J.: When I
was starting out I had the same vision that most
filmmakers do. I’m going to make this low-budget
movie and I’m going to put it in film festivals
and it’s going to get discovered and some big
distributor is going to pick it up and it’s going
to take off and I’m going to be Spike Lee or I’m
going to be Quentin Tarantino or I’m going to
be Robert Rodriguez and that’s what it takes to
be able to make a living doing movies. But it’s
not, there’s a whole sub-level of working class
filmmakers that are making movies that a lot of
people would consider backyard movies, movies
shot for $10,000 or $20,000 or $30,000 and there
are people out there that are making these movies
and can make livings off of them. You might not be
rich, I’m not on red carpets and I’m not getting
Oscars and awards and all of that but I’m doing
what I love to do. I’m making a living at it and
to be really honest and a lot of people will say
that I'm I'm rationalizing it because I'm not at
the higher level but honestly at this point in
my career like I don't want to be much higher
don't get me wrong if I stumbled on a $500,000
budget as opposed to a 50 that'd be great i'd
love to do that but as far as like directing like
studio films or tentpole stuff I have absolutely
no desire to do that any anymore I did when I
started but not now but I really wish somebody had
made it known to me that like you don't
necessarily have to be Quentin Tarantino
to make a living making movies it's interesting
how people's desires for success change and maybe
you get tastes of it here and you realize what
this is a lot of stress over here I kind of like
this realm where I'm doing my own thing I'm still
accountable but I don't have to be there's a price
to pay I think for certain levels of a career
yeah yeah totally and one thing that's always
been a not a problem but a a source of anxiety for
me especially when I have outside investors like
I feel you know a moral and and of course a legal
responsibility to return the money and when you're
making movies for fifty thousand dollars or
sixty thousand dollars or twenty thousand dollars
most of the people that are investing in those
movies are not super rich people because like real
like rich experienced investors they're not
going to invest in a $60,000 movie and not
because it can't be profitable but because
there's a ceiling to how profitable it can be
like yes sky is the limit but it's outliers for
the most part if you do a hundred movies at 50 000
the most one of those is going to make in a year
in general terms is like maybe a couple hundred
thousand and that's like at the tippity top so
for a a regular investor somebody that invests
millions of dollars or they have big they're
that's just not an exciting investment they're
like what I'm going to put $60,000 and two years
later I'm going to get $150,000 back or maybe
$200,000 it's just not so it's so the people
that are investing in these movies are usually
people like myself that we're we're making modest
livings we have a good year we might have $10,000
or $15,000 that we can throw towards something and
we do and but so then as a filmmaker when you get
that money you have all this you want to be able
to return it one of my movies I produced back
in 2010 and it was a I think a $35,000 budget and
one of the producers who i'd worked with for years
he had it it's finally our project to work
together and he had come into some like family
money a family member had passed or something
like that so he had a little bit of a nest egg
and he ended up putting like fifteen thousand
dollars into that movie so eventually the movie
made its money back but it took a long time
and and I felt that every day until that money
was returned that's just how I like like me
as a filmmaker I can't take money and then
not return it and feel okay and I'm still my last
narrative film which I know my tagline is I make
movies that make money but my last narrative film
the campus death day it was a financial failure it
didn't make its budget back and there was quite a
few like two and three thousand dollar investors
in that that they could really use that money
and they never made it and I I’ll always feel
bad about that was there a moment jay when the
Hollywood dream was no more you just wanted to be
a working-class filmmaker or a middle-class
filmmaker I would say I would say it pro like
maybe around five years ago it started
to occur to me that hey maybe like I'm
not going to be directing million dollar movies
but but I still I still kind of hold on to it
still like that like that's the goal but somewhere
in the last like two years like moving out to
Georgia and doing the documentaries full-time
and and honestly doing my youtube channel
like I just I just realized that I don't I
really don't even desire that anymore I like
I don't desire the red carpet stuff anymore or the
adulation of millions or whatever it is it's just
it really became about the work and what I think
what really changed for me for the better and I
recommend this for like all filmmakers when you
stop making movies a hundred percent for yourself
and start making them for others is when
things change at least it did for me
when I stopped thinking about my little precious
passion project and I start thinking about like
with the documentaries for example I'm making
a dog rescue documentary and I'm bringing
awareness to this issue and this this small
little dog rescue that might be struggling like
that's what making that movie was about and then a
byproduct of that it can be financially successful
or even I'm getting ready to do a horror movie
craving my first narrative in a few years
and but totally this isn't just like hey
this is my script that I wanted to make
the whole time I'm like what is the sub genre what
is the audience expecting from the sub genre what
can I give them to make this better and and I
think that that leads to more practical success
you had been in LA how many years
15 15. so you came here from Georgia
now when you came out here too okay so originally
I was from Indiana I grew up in Indiana
and it didn't really seem like I was really into
movies like I was a small kid I didn't really
play sports I just watched movies so but there
was no like it didn't seem like that was a real
thing that you could do like I was shooting little
videos and stuff but it never crossed my mind
before I moved out of Indiana that movies are
something that I could do and make some money
at it's like you had to be in Los Angeles or New
York or you had to be just famous and discovered
and I moved from Indiana to Louisiana I worked
offshore for about a year and a half save some
money for college and then decided I was going to
go to school and the university of New Orleans had
a pretty good film program and so I went there
I studied communications and film and this was
right around the time that Panasonic released
their dvx 100 the 24p mini dv camera yeah and
all of a sudden and in like what is it 28 days
later it'd come out and I was like oh it's like
it's suddenly feasible to like shoot a feature
film and so I started thinking more about it
as like a practical career and that right after I
graduated college that summer we pulled together
a few thousand dollars and that's when we shot
rise of the undead which was my first movie.